bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
avec un sujet qui concerne beaucoup de
bourguignons nous allons aujourd'hui
nous pencher sur l'avenir des petites
villes et des villes moyennes
après un rapport récent qui analysent
une désertification commerciale
alarmante des centres-villes trois
maires avec nous sur ce plateau marie
claude jarrot bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maire les républicains de
montceau-les-mines en saône-et-loire
denis thuriau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maire sans étiquette de nevers nevers
qui dans leur rapport dont je parlais
figure parmi les villes les plus
touchées par ce phénomène et bernard
moraine bonjour bonjour liant maire
divers gauche de joigny dans l'yonne on
se souvient que jouanny avait été
qualifiée de ville martyre pour les
fermetures des services de l'état alors
denis thuriau nevers dans ce rapport se
situe à plus de 15% de vacances
commercial c'est-à-dire de boutiques qui
reste fermé comment est ce que une ville
se retrouve dans cette situation c'est
brutal où c'est progressif mais génial
constat que je ferais très rapidement
qu'il y a plusieurs causes
tout d'abord une grosse baisse
démographique que dans notre département
et a fortiori dans la ville centre et
puis ensuite une absence de
modernisation de la ville un dossier
intéressés et état aussi des bâtiments
publiques mais bâtiments privés donc une
fois qu'on a fait ce constat on essayait
de mettre en place des leviers et
d'autant plus quand on est mis à l'index
faut réagir encore plus pourquoi parce
que le commerce de coeur de ville c'est
le coeur
voilà une ville qui n'a plus de coeur il
est une ville qui ne vit plus donc ça ça
a démarré par une reprise en contact
avec les associations de commerçants
avec un dialogue qui est permanent qui
est récurrent et un soutien que nous
avons multiplié par quatre depuis 2014
financier moyens techniques etc
après je suis convaincu ça n'est pas une
seule chose c'est tout un tas de levier
on mise beaucoup sur le numérique vous
savez qu'on mettrait en avant sur le
territoire de la nasa
mes rations et de la vie de nos verres
donc c'est aussi le commerce connecté
mais internet ne doit pas faire peur aux
commerçants doivent se l'approprier et
ça doit être un outil supplémentaire
on va y venir au levier sur le constat
est sûre cette préoccupation bernard
moraine et marie claude jarrot mais
bernard moraine d'abord on les maires
ils ont beaucoup de choses à penser
avec eux on parle des banlieues on parle
de beaucoup de choses mais le
centre-ville c'est quand les gens voient
des boutiques fermées dans un centre
ville
c'est peut-être une des choses dont ils
parlent le plus et le maire il reçoit
cette préoccupation évidemment oui mais
est-ce qu'un maire en 2016 s'il peut
quelque chose sur des décisions qui ont
été prises dans les années 1980 1990
d'abord une évolution de la pratique
commerciale le développement dans new
périphérie de deux zones commerciales ça
c'est qu'il a maîtrisée personnes la
maîtriser et puis le changement
d'habitudes des consommateurs
on ne va plus de chez les petits
commerçants
on va plutôt dans les grandes surfaces
les grandes surfaces la grande
distribution qui elle aussi est menacée
à terme par le e-commerce ça ça ça va
jouer aussi
et donc il faut effectivement entre
autres à joigny par l'aspect médiévale
de son centre ville qui présente des
énormes difficultés
c'est à dire que le bâti médiéval par
exemple offre aux commerçants des
petites surfaces et ckoi maintenant les
données 2d des commerces et des plus
grandes surfaces donc il ya tout le
travail on en parlera tout à l'heure
mais tout le travail est fait une pause
et vert voilà ce qu'on peut faire
puisque je crois qu'on a mené le seul
exemple actuellement en france dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville ou à
la fois on travaille sur les quartiers
classique
j'allais dire de nos quartiers
populaires mais aussi et c'est là une
grande nouveauté
on va travailler sur le coeur de ville
sur la cité médiévale
marie claude jarrot même chose le maire
il reçoit le retour des citoyens qui
disent mais là il ya plus de boulangerie
là il n'y a plus rien
et on voit à vendre ou à louer sur les
boutiques alors effectivement le maire
reçoit toutes les doléances des citoyens
mais le maire est en charge aussi de
travailler avec les commerçants sur sur
la redynamisation du centre ville
il n'y a pas de fatalité sur ce sujet
nous nous avons des leviers à utiliser
des leviers financiers des leviers liés
aux différentes lois qui nous permette
de préempter qui nous permettent de
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle les
dents creuses donc d'encre c'est quoi
c'est des endroits où il ya plus rien ou
personne veut s'installer qui sont pas
là ce sont des endroits où il n'y a plus
rien et où personne ne veut s'installer
et puis nous avons aussi à construire
mes collègues viennent de le dire une
stratégie commerciale par rapport à
notre identification de notre zone
d'attractivité à montceau-les-mines la
ville vingt mille habitants zones
d'attractivité commerciale
environ cent quarante mille habitants
donc nous avons à travailler sur un
certain nombre de leviers notamment
nous avons choisi nous la gratuité des
parkings nous avons choisi un accès tout
à fait privilégié au centre ville et
puis nous avons un atout très très
intéressant très intéressant c'est que
nos zones commerciales sont à proximité
très très près 500 mètres du centre ce
cas par cas et ça c'est véritablement à
à construire dans à utiliser dans le
cadre de la stratégie comme hier alors
vous avez parlé de levier et moi j'ai
envie de vous demander
il ya la discussion il ya l'incitation
mais est-ce que de votre point de vue
les maires et doivent aussi un moment
donné prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
radicales et je me tourne vers vous
denis therriault parce que voilà c'est
si la mesure vous venez prendre on va
dire en instaurant une taxe sur les
commerces vacants pour bourg dire ça de
façon très simple expliquez-nous d'abord
pourquoi vous avez décidé d'être
beaucoup plus impératif on va dire
épiler vous nous direz aussi ce que vous
pensez de ce type de mesures de
nettoyage
oui et c'est une continuité ce qu'ils
viennent de dire mes collègues d'abord
il faut avoir une politique globale et
c'est pas sur une chose ou du
saupoudrage qu'on y arrive
et c'est aussi travailler en lien avec
les commerçants parce que c'est aussi à
eux d'avoir un dynamisme on n'est pas
des commerçants et on ne vend rien par
contre on essaye d'aider et à nova une
premat xp mental je voulais tout à
l'heure c'est grande disproportion sur
les autres périphériques avec un nombre
de mètres carrés notamment commerce
alimentaire qui était le plus important
des villes moyennes au ca a été voulu à
l'époque je vais pas faire comme mon
opposition qui me dit faut tout raser
c'est aussi du commerce des emplois
d'activité par contre faut mettre tout
le monde en lien et faire travailler
ensemble
c'est ce qu'on a fait symboliquement
dire par un petit train l'an dernier et
aujourd'hui c'est l'association se
parlent entre elles sur le partage donc
voilà il faut faire ce trait d'union
après effectivement moi j'ai été pendant
deux ans dans la citation trouver des
pistes communes oph vous permettre de
rénover parce qu'on sait que les gens
qui aident en ville il ya aussi profiter
d'un cadre agréable et notre zone
piétonne à plus de 35 ans en rénovation
c'est aussi un gros enjeu alors j'ai pas
ça va tenir dans le mandat et puis c'est
aussi beaucoup de contraintes et je m'y
intéresse et puis ensuite il ya des
leviers près vitrine rénové aujourd'hui
un propriétaire qui a meublé avec de
l'habitat
ce qui pose problème parce que il y
avait souvent qu'un seul accès avant le
commerçant habiter au sud
il faut aussi d'y joindre et donc de
l'habitat une vitrine rénové quasiment
un prêt à taux zéro on peut refaire une
belle vitrine une belle façade il passe
actuellement des covering des vitrines
c'est pas un gadget
et ça a permis d'attirer le regard sur
des choses qui étaient oubliés parce que
désespérément fermée depuis des années
et d'ailleurs on a un certain nombre
d'ouvertures suite à cette action
c'est vous dire ça devait pas suffire
vous vu la décision vous mais pourtant
on va suffire parce que il ya une autre
problématique aussi faux que les
bailleurs soient raisonnables on s'est
rendu compte qu'un avère les prix
étaient excessifs excessif et j'espère
qu'à jouer pour remonter mais en l'état
y sont excessifs
donc j'ai demandé à ce qu'on en tient
compte et notre service développement
économique a d'ailleurs ac dans la
négociation fait baisser des prix soit
pour des nouveaux porteurs soit par des
gens qui étaient en difficulté pour
arriver à des prix raisonnables et mon
idée effectivement c'était de proposer
ce qui était votée au dernier conseil
municipal la taxe sur les friches
commerciales donc sur les locaux vacants
pourquoi parce que ça ne bénéficie pas
aux commerces à côté si à une
discontinuité aux touristes aux
riverains
et puis en plus si ces vacances pendant
des années c'est qu'il ya une raison
c'est quand on veut vendre une maison
dans les tourelles à vendre mais une
question de prix une question de trouver
la bonne personne donc pareil pour un
local donc aujourd'hui je suis parti sur
le maximum c'est que j'ai doublé les
taux minimum donc
aujourd'hui ses 20 30 ou 40% sur
première deuxième troisième année sur
une disque on propose l'administration
fiscale c'est qui est intéressant c'est
que je suis pas je suis pas dans une
optique de te taper sur tout le monde
avec le bâton je suis plutôt dans une
optique de faire des réactions mais un
certain nombre de bayan déjà pris
contact avec moi j'ai rencontrés m'ont
donné d'explications faut qu'ils
avancent et puis s'il a une bonne raison
pour laquelle locaux sont pas loués mais
ils peuvent être exonérés de cette
surtaxe
mais ma première idée c'est aussi de
motiver ceux qui se désintéressent il ya
des gros propriétaires qui ne vivent pas
là qui se dit c'est pas grave si c'est
pas louer c'est pas admissible pour les
autres alors oui à tous les trois on a
les mêmes problématiques
le constat qui est fait à nevers à
montceau jouanny et c'est très bien il
nous faut des outils
effectivement nous aussi on a fait
ensemble de démarches comme couvrir les
vitrines vides
on a aussi mon prédécesseur avait acheté
quelques boutiques dans la rue piétonne
et nous on y met des tarifs très bas
est ce que disait denis therriault
l'instant effectivement nous on est
aussi ce problème là de propriétaires
qui sont à l'autre bout de à l'autre
bout de la france qui des fois ne se
souviennent pas qu'ils ont un bien joli
voyez genre propriétaire 86 ans il
souvient paris habitat biarritz et
souviens pas qu'il avait un truc à
joigny l'autre problématique il nous
faut les outils juridiques aussi car on
le maire faut le savoir
le maire n'a pas la main sur la
destination future d'un magasin moi j'ai
pas envie d'un énième et bave
qu'est-ce qui fait le maire qu'est ce
qui peut faire le rcc extrêmement
compliqué parce qu'il n'a pas la maladie
su c'est la liberté du commerce
alors après on peut aller voir le futur
entrepreneur en attendait ça va être la
énième dans la même rue vous faites que
dire beaucoup d'experts c'est que les
commerces de base sont pendant sa trempe
là c'est parce qu'on appelle des
commerces de superflu dire que on trouve
des gens mais
oui pierce moi ce que ce qui est
dangereux aussi c'est que il faut bien
on va pas se le cacher il ya des
commerçants talentueux il y en a qu ils
sont pas hélas qui sont faits pour être
commerçant est là qui sont pas faits
pour être commerçant il ya des gens qui
ont changé de destination
la mairie a été on voit les images radar
qui a été fait sur les commerçants de
jouer ni ça c'est une autre forme
d'action
oui là pour le coup c'est le lien avec
le jonças ce bouquin qui a été tiré à
3000 ou 4000 exemplaires ça ça a été
vraiment une belle démarche parce que
c'est de montrer que le tissu commercial
adjoignent est très important en gros
c'est à dire
n'allez pas à sens n'allait pas à
auxerre il ya tout ce qu'il faut à
joigny et c'est vrai qu'on a gagné là
dessus parce que le le maître mot qui a
été dit après quand ça a été diffusé ses
dires abat on savait pas qui était le
magasin on savait pas qu'il y avait un
tel produit qui était vendu à jouer
alors là on a eu on tape fort on avoue
nous avait expliqué ce que vous en
pensiez sur le manque d'outils
juridiques il nous faudrait un et claude
jarrot vous êtes vous avez envie de dire
aux propriétaires maintenant ça suffit
alors concernant les propriétaires jeu
j'y reviendrai dans quelques minutes
simplement sur la fiscalité sur les
locaux vides
nous nous avons pris un autre un autre
chemin et j'ai pour habitude de dire que
nous sommes des bâtisseurs et non pas
des percepteurs
donc je préfère le travail que nous
avons démarré et qui porte ses fruits
mais pas à 100% un faut quand même dire
les choses sur l'inventaire des
propriétaires et mon collègue de joigny
a raison il y à des propriétaires qui
habitent très loin qui se souviennent
peut-être pas du tout mais qu'ils se
souviennent très peu qu'ils ont un local
commercial à louer premièrement
deuxièmement ce look un commercial
souvent il le loue très cher donc j'ai
initié un travail sur l'interpellation
et non pas la fiscalité refusons sur
l'instant sur l'interpellation zones en
tension
si ça fonctionne sur l'interpellation de
ces propriétaires qui pour certains se
sont rendus
on rejoint notre cause et ont baissé les
le montant niveau le montant du loyer
autres autre poids sur la problématique
de l'accessibilité
il faut aussi bien dire que nous avons
dans nos budgets à nous intéresser sur
la problème à la problématique de
l'accessibilité c'est à dire que les
commerçants
il faut qu'il rende leurs locaux
accessibles ça leur fait peur ça leur
fait peur parce que ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent donc nous avons aussi nous un
levier d'accompagnement des commerçants
si nous les accompagnons dans cette
difficulté liée à la l'accessibilité
alors vous avez évoqué les commerces de
base et des commerces de superflu sur ce
sujet les maires nous avons un travail à
faire c'est à dire dans le cas de la
rénovation de nos centres villes
nous avons à nous prononcer et ça ça
fait partie du courage aussi à nous
prononcer sur l' équilibre entre les
commerces de base et les commerces
superflu et je crois que nos concitoyens
ils entendent ils entendent ça avec avec
intérêt parce que évidemment il faut pas
qu est que des commerces superflu et pas
de commerce de base parce que si on veut
ramener si on veut ramener des habitants
en centre ville avec le logement il nous
faut aussi parler de notre politique de
logement mais vos et qu'elle vous
élargissez et vous me permettez de nous
amener à la suite parce que la question
une fois qu'on a parlé de commerce est
de savoir est ce que ces difficultés
commerciales c'est uniquement commercial
ou est ce qu'on est et c'est le symptôme
des difficultés aujourd'hui d'une partie
de villes en france beaucoup d'experts
le 10/10 que la ville va faire ça n'est
que le premier symptôme d'autres choses
bernard moraine oui bien sûr évidemment
oui évidemment quel exemple il est des
parts des services de l'état
il ya des allusions tout à l'heure au
début de cette émission qu'est-ce qu'on
a pris comme coup sur la figure à chaque
fois qu'il y avait une réforme comme on
dit hospitalière fermeture de la
maternité et la chirurgie justice
fermeture du tribunal d'instance fait
rupture du tribunal de commerce est la
cerise sur le gâteau genre 48 heures
après l'arrivée de deux mois mais elles
sauront siège de 2 le maire de joigny
fermeture de du gru géographie 410
personnel civil et militaire
un seul chiffre que jeunes à chaque fois
pour donner la réalité des choses
quand le comptable du groupe
géographique avait fini de faire les
paye tous les mois
il en avait fait pour sept cent mille
euros donc ces sept cent mille euros qui
ne retombe plus chaque mois dans
l'économie locale etc et c'est pour ça
que joie n'y a hélas rejoint le le
mauvais club le club desservant les plus
pauvres de france
et c'est toute la difficulté je sais pas
si on a le temps de payer de charges de
centralité mais des villes pauvres comme
nous on n'est plus en capacité
d'accueillir toutes les tous les
citoyens concitoyens qui habitent autour
de nos villes c'est une grande
difficulté qui fait aussi qui alors si
si on essaie de prendre un peu de
hauteur là dessus est ce qu on a
beaucoup parlé de finances publiques
d'économies enfin il y avait des
motivations pour l'état à tout ce que
vous décrivez est ce qu'à un moment
donné vous qui êtes aux commandes de
villes petites ou moyennes on va dire
dans la typologie française vous avez
l'impression que ceux qui dirigent et
qui prennent les décisions se sont ne
prennent pas la mesure boeuf que sont
ces villes
denis thuriau et de leurs difficultés
d'une façon générale je pense qu'on le
dénonce touche on est souvent victime
des technocrates pas forcément des élus
nationaux d'ailleurs qui finalement
prennent des décisions sur des rapports
de technocrates qu'ils connaissent pas
le terrain on n'a pas tout à fait les
mêmes difficultés en tant que ville
préfecture on a moins subi ce que
voulait créer il ya d'autres causes
mais par contre je me rappelle quand
j'étais bâtonnier de l'ordre et qu'on
voulait supprimer les tribunaux de
grande instance
on n'a pas tenu compte des réalités
quand on voulait fermer la maison
d'arrêt de nevers en disant de verser en
bourgogne doxa côté de dijon décision
par des mois mais stupide
bon on a gardé maison d'arrêt sinon on
aurait désocialisés les gens je vois pas
aussi dans un territoire qui est quand
même en difficulté comme la nièvre les
familles pour aller voir les détenus
régulièrement c'est important donc pour
en revenir aux cieux qui nous qui nous
occupes l'après mathy pour nevers est
encore une fois des différentes mais
c'est vrai qu'à certaines décisions qui
ne nous aide pas on a quand même un
certain nombre d'éléments à pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre à moi du père noël je
pas non plus apparaître que comme le
père fouettard et je ne sais pas que
taper a bien évidemment mais cette
mesure de fiscalité jeu les prises en
désespoir de cause faute de réaction
parce que pendant deux ans j'avais
annoncé la couleur
et encore une fois ce que je souhaite
c'est pas forcément l'appliquer avec ça
crée des réactions par contre ce que je
constate quand même c'est que depuis
presque trois ans le taux de vacance
était en augmentation de 9% et les trois
années précédentes
aujourd'hui je dis qu'il n'est plus que
de 3 c'est insuffisant mais ça veut dire
qu'on arrive à baisser aujourd'hui et il
ya un nombre de commerces qui ouvrent
aussi on oublie enfin de ce qui charme
on parle pas de ceux qui jouaient là on
a des exemples encore ce week-end à
nevers où il ya trois quatre commerces
qui souvent en zone piétonne dont le
commerce est aussi vivant et vous avez
raison de le dire il ya des commerçants
qui ont pas bon parce qu'être
commerçants c'est aussi gérer c'est
aussi faire de la compta mais j'ai vu
des choses aberrantes alors maintenant
on va pas taper sur nos amis commerçants
mais il faut aussi qu'ils proposent de
la qualité et si on veut que le commerce
de coeur de ville aussi se distingue ce
n'est pas de proposer à une chose que
des zones périphériques
c'est de la qualité ou des choses qu'on
ne trouve pas ou du commerce de
centre-ville où la ville est faible au
centre ville vivant lille n'a plus de
coeur et les difficultés qu'on a on fait
qu'on a été choisi par la caisse des
dépôts enfin nous a proposé mais nous
avons accepté comme vie démonstrateur il
ya dix villes en france vit
démonstrateur ce qui nous permet de
travailler en réseau et en lien échanger
sur les difficultés prendre des bonnes
idées parce qu'on les a pas tous donc
faut se départager de temps en temps et
puis également pouvoir bénéficier d'une
démarche expérimentale pendant deux ans
on fera un bilan avec l'aide de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations qui
nous met des moyens d'ingénierie qui
nous met des co-investissements à
disposition des aides à des financements
et d'idc d'identifier mais très
précisément des zones
parce que faut aussi avoir conscience
que peut-être le la zone commerçante qui
a 40 ans et plus il faut plus vouloir
qu'elle soit la même aujourd'hui c'est
une erreur donc il ya des choses qui
sont changés c'est pour ça que nous ça
nous aide dans une démarche urbanistique
de mettre des zones piétonnes nouvelle
c'est compliqué il ya les pros y aller
contre de mettre des choses en tout cas
partagé et donc c'est intéressant et
j'ai jeu mais bon espoir aussi dans ce
qui est un outil supplémentaire à
utiliser vous décrivez quand même c'est
que il ya une prise de conscience aussi
d'un certain nombre de services
aujourd'hui de cette difficulté vous
dites il ya des outils a quand même
j'ai l'impression puisqu'on cherche à
faire à des choses innovantes
moi je le fais notamment j'ai parlé du
numérique mettre le wifi access gratuit
c'est important aujourd'hui on est
chacun sur nos smartphones on veut faire
la meilleure affaire si vous l'avez en
deux minutes et vous savez que c'est à
côté plutôt que d'aller à l'extérieur
c'est gagné pour nos commerçants coeur
de ville marie claude jarrot l'attend
avec impatience
oui si je n'ai pas beaucoup je voudrais
dire que les commerçants sur cette
opération du centre ville reste nos
interlocuteurs privilégiés mais nous
devons agir par rapport à toutes nos
offres
c'est à dire l'offre commerciale du
centre-ville l'offre du commerce de
périphérie
l'offre culturelle parce que ça c'est
important
si on a des villes moyennes donc on peut
tout à fait organiser une activité
culturelle dans notre centre ville à
côté de l'activité commerçante l'offre
sportive la proximité il faut qu'on joue
la carte de la proximité de notre image
de proximité et qui va nous rendre plus
attractif et moi je ne suis pas
absolument pas démoralisé par rapport au
centre ville je pense que nous avons une
belle de beaux projets nous avons écrit
nous écrivons les maires la nouvelle
page de la redynamisation des centres
villes et ça ça me paraît ça me paraît
fondamental après après le travail avec
les commerçants il doit se faire en
confiance parce que c'est pas toujours
facile les commerçants 1 mais puisque
nous sommes dans des villes moyennes ou
des villes petit on peut très bien
répondre à leurs demandes
cette année les commerçants sont venus
voir l'association des commerçants émue
moi en disant il faut fermer la rue la
rue piétonne sur toute sa longueur
ok on y va en septembre eh ben c'est
peut-être pas une bonne idée
on va rouvrir une partie de la rue
piétonne oui mais notre proximité est le
fait que nous soyons maire de petite ou
de moyenne ville ça permet de faire ça
c'est facile donc
pendons sur l'opérationnel maillaud une
vision stratégique urbanistique de plus
quand nous avons la chance d'avoir des
cours d'eau en ce qui me concerne j'ai
le canal du centre
on peut tout à fait organisée autour du
syntras de la loi de nature à compliquer
tout c'est la bourbince le canal du
centre qui est à côté du centre ville eh
bien il faut il faut exploiter il faut
développer ses potentiels qui sont très
intéressants le tourisme fluvial
ça fait venir des des acheteurs dans la
vie c'est proximité jouant la carte de
la jarre occident nous dressait un
tableau qui est plutôt rose pardonne moi
c'est pas exactement ce que le rapport
l'inspection des finances dit sur la
plupart des villes moyennes en france
qui sont quand même dans une situation
difficile à ce sujet donc c'est pas
c'est pas si vous permettez c'est pas un
tableau c'est pas un tableau plutôt rose
puisque c'est le sait le canal du centre
qui passe ça serait plutôt de l'eau
bleue mais concernant concernant notre
capacité ce que ce que je veux faire
passer comme comme et ça c'est que
concernant cette capacité que nous avons
nous les maires à avoir notre strate
d'une stratégie commerciale à mettre en
oeuvre une stratégie commerciale
il faut avec les commerçants nous faire
confiance et mon collègue a parlé de la
caisse des dépôts qui accompagne d'une
manière tout à fait significatives et
engager les villes pour se reconstruire
maman est ce que au delà tout ça on a
parlé un petit peu je pense qu'on est
tous les trois touchés par plutôt une
baisse de la démographie
oui devenir un navet
dit tout à l'heure alors qu'est ce qui
se passe en fait c'est que nos villes
les villes-centres on est des
villes-centres on est des 80 par rapport
aux autres de commune d'à côté nos
villes centres baisse des fois au profit
des communes qui autour
mais ces communes qu'il ya autour elles
ont déjà perdu leur boulangerie elles
ont déjà perdu la pharmacie et et ça va
pas et cette augmentation cette petite
augmentation de la démographie dans les
petits villages dans les petites
communes ne fait par honnêteté commerce
donc en fait c'est tout qui s'appauvrit
et moi j'attends j'attends un vrai geste
fiscal de la part du gouvernement à
venir c'est c'est de prendre en compte
les charges de centralité je cite lilian
un exemple le on a grand club sportif
qui s'appellent union sportive julienne
l'union sportive juniel regroupe 19
sections ces deux mille adhérents plus
de 2000 adhérents ce qui est quand même
pas mal
sur les 2000 adhérents il ya 800 julien
1200 non-jeu vignes et qui paye les
installations qui entretient les
attaquants sportive que les
contribuables
je vis bien et là il ya un truc qui va
pas et je pourrais multiplier dans le
domaine de la culture
notre médiathèque nous reste quatre
minutes d'émission je vous bernard
moraine parce qu'à une question vous
avez envie de vous poser qui est dans
l'est le début des campagnes électorales
qui commence on aura très peu de temps
pour en parler c'est l'expression à la
mode c'est la france périphérique ce
serait cette idée qu à côté des grandes
métropoles
il ya une autre france aujourd'hui
qu'est celle des petites villes et des
villes moyennes et que c'est aussi là
dedans que ceux qui labourent le
populisme vont chercher parce qu'un
certain nombre de gens ont l'impression
que c'est vivre sans oublier et que ça
marche pas denis quirion oui c'est vrai
vous êtes les maires de la france
périphérique wii moi j'ai pas ce terme
moi je suis un maire dans un département
rural je suis un maire d'une ville et
d'une haie et un présidents
d'agglomérations d'une zone urbaine ou
périurbaine et ça il faut le revendiquer
très fort on est à deux heures de paris
deux heures de dijon théoriquement quand
tout va bien le positionnement nous que
je revendique et je souhaite pas
uniquement à voir les miettes donc ça
c'est clair
en revanche quand on parle de projet
global c'est un projet aussi ça servira
au maire quand je suis arrivé à la
mairie allait 70% des voix qui sortait
du centre et 30% qui arrive est géré
équilibré j'ai fais vraiment une
politique de stationnement développement
des zones bleues et c'est sur un
quartier qui avait été pour le coup
abandonné on avait enlevé des services
je pense au quartier des courriers qu'on
rénove on remet du commerce intéressant
c est nouveau c'est inéluctable
sensations il faut compter sur nous et
si en plus on a des cerises sur le
gâteau je les mange mais autrement on
compte sur nous et je compte aussi sur
notre cellule d'accompagnement je donne
cet exemple très concret dans notre
service développement économique elle a
reçu à peu près une centaine
d'implantations commerçante sur
l'induction n'est plus compétence agglo
et bien il ya à peu près 12 qui ont
répondu oui et on douvres donc voilà ça
veut dire qu'il peut y avoir du réseau
faut être patient faut être construits
réfléchi cohérent dans tout ce qu'on met
en place et c'est pas un levier d'action
qui va nous sauver c'est plat et puis
donner une meilleure image de nous ça ça
relève aussi de nos politiques
aujourd'hui l'avenir et pas que dans les
métropoles il est peut-être surtout
d'ailleurs dans des zones moyenne comme
on les représente tous parce que
finalement c'est là où il ya le plus de
français moi je suis un garçon toujours
optimiste je suis juste un petit peu
inquiet parce que il nous reste encore
quelques services publics à l'hôpital
400 agents médecins et infirmières
administratif et on a encore le centre
des impôts quand j'entends les candidats
de votre camp supprimer encore plein de
fonctionnaires on va finir par tuer des
communes comme jouanny où il n'ya pas
l'industrie est historiquement chauny
c'était la ville de garnison
historiquement johnny était une ville
administrative comment va faire moi je
pose la question
ben justement il nous reste une minute
par claude jarrot même sens nous sommes
les maires de la france qui respire
il n'y a pas que les métropoles il y à
des personnes qui habitent dans les
zones rurales ou urbaines et nous sommes
les maires de la france qui respire le
centre ville puisque c'est ce dont nous
parlions ce matin le centre ville le
centre ville et le cordon ombilical
entre l'individu et le vivre ensemble
donc nous concluons pas sur une fatalité
non non ce n'était pas l'objectif mais
c'était très long nous allons
redynamiser nos centres villes avec des
stratégies en utilisant tous nos leviers
et je crois qu'on peut nous faire
confiance au monde il faudra que ce soit
dans la prochaine campagne électorale à
venir
c'est important parce qu'on n'en parle
jamais les maires bien il le sait
détermine que l'église ne faut pas qu'on
se demande d une fatalité faut qu'on
soit dans des facilités et nous devons
nous des facilitateurs c'est comme ça
qu'on est perçue avec les commerçants
avec lesquels on est en confiance et qui
ne donnent leur rythme il serait temps
de se saisir des vrais problèmes
merci à tous les trois on est à la fin
de ce débat merci à tous les trois est
venu nous faire part de votre expérience
restez avec nous la deuxième partie de
dimanche en politique c'est pierre
laurent secrétaire national du parti
communiste qui sera l'invité de francis
letellier
bon dimanche au revoir et merci